As a startup, and learning all this
great data within Google Analytics,
I think the best advice I
would say is stick with it.
It's a lot of information, and I think
a lot of people think it's a little
daunting because they don't
know where to get started.
What's really great is that we have
a lot of amazing tutorials online.
There's actually a video overview
that kind of walks them through
the different steps.
Talks about someone who's a bit more,
you know, has implemented and
maybe used it a little bit more further
than like a brand new start up can
give them all the tips and
tricks to be successful.
So I think the best advice is
to keep at it and don't give up.
And make sure that you can
get help along the way.